nikki kinnaird launched space nk in the
early 90s as her personal edit of the
world's best beauty products the
apothecary now operates 62 stores across
the uk
lipstick economics suggests consumers
still buy pricey makeup in tough
economic times and space nk has kept
growing we opened the doors in the uk in
1993 when british high street obviously
was suffering but i think we benefited
from some of the money coming from
fashion into
makeup and beauty
the international business includes 23
stores and concessions in the us
alongside a growing online presence but
future aspirations may lie in the east
the internet has opened space nk to a
global customer
personally i have aspirations always
have of that it would be fabulous to be
able to open in southeast asia if you
look at countries like japan and korea
where there's such a heritage and
people welcome
skin care regimens
nikki's passion for the beauty world
started in childhood and it's passion
that she says makes for successful
business
i think if you want to be an
entrepreneur you've got to be truly
passionate about what you're involved in
because anyone can be good at anything
but if you feel
passion for that particular topic you're
going to do the job so much better and
what about getting outside money
involved i know you've had private
equity money involved in the business i
assume you have to give up a little bit
of control if you have other people's
money involved absolutely for me it was
always more than having just money it
was other people's expertise that comes
on board you can always find money
somewhere but it's getting the right
money with the right mindset behind
there you want people involved who've
got a common goal so you're all going in
the same direction